meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren
liebe Freunde und Freundinnen des
heeresgeschichtlichen Museums
schön dass sie heute so zahlreich
erschienen sind mein Name ist Thomas
Reichel und ich darf Sie durch den
heutigen Abend führen
es freut uns sehr dass wir heute holen
Besuch haben ich begrüße den
militäradache der Schweiz Herrn Oberst
im Generalstab ursulzer herzlich
willkommen
[Applaus]
weiters begrüße ich den Vizepräsidenten
unseres Fördervereins virusunitis Herrn
Brigadier in Ruhe Professor Magister
Rolf Bures herzlich willkommen
[Applaus]
seit dem 15 Februar hat unser Museum
eine neue Führung gemeinsam mit Direktor
Georg Hoffmann den ich im Anschluss noch
vorstellen werde hat unser Haus auch mit
Frau Magistra Stefanie brachersdorfer
eine neue Verwaltungsdirektorin bekommen
schön dass sie heute da sind
[Applaus]
dr Georg Hoffmann ist in Graz geboren wo
auch seine Schulausbildung absolviert
hat danach folgte eine ef-ausbildung
Waffengattung Fliegerabwehr er hat in
dieser Funktion er war
batteriekommandant S1 und S5 und hat
sich darüber hinaus auch als
informationsoffizier betätigt und hat
diese Tätigkeit bis heute über die
weiter aus sogar noch eine Stufe darüber
daher direkt aber heute den ganzen Tag
damit beschäftigt informationsoffiziere
des Bundesheeres auszubilden und auch
den morgigen Tag wieder dies noch tun
also das heißt dieser Tätigkeit ist
danach wie vor sehr verbunden und das
Weiteren ist der Militärexperte für
Geschichte im Kommando Streitkräfte
sein Studium der Geschichte die Blumen
und Doktoratsstudium Summer cum laude
hat er ebenfalls in Graz absolviert
seine Forschungsschwerpunkte sind
Militärgeschichte
kultursozialwirtschafts- und
Politikgeschichte von Krieg Konflikt und
Gewalt Erinnerung und Gedächtnis
Nationalsozialismus Luftkrieg und
Verwaltungsgeschichte
unter seinen zahlreichen Forschungs- und
Ausstellungsprojekten sowie
Lehrtätigkeiten in Österreich und den
USA finden sich Themen wie
schlachtfeldarchäologie k+k-
Fachsprache zu bleiben jetzt endlich im
heeresgeschichtlichen Museum gelandet
alles Gute für die herausfordernde
Tätigkeit
Waffen Uniformen und
Ausrüstungsgegenstände nur sehen sind
stumme Zeugen vergangener Zeit sie
können keine Geschichte erzählen
Geschichte erzählen können nur Menschen
ihre Erinnerungen sind es die uns zeigen
wie es damals war bzw wie die
Betroffenen das damals erlebte
wahrgenommen haben
Geschichte wird erst lebendig wenn wir
uns mit den betroffenen Menschen und
ihren Erinnerungen in welcher Form uns
diese auch immer überliefert sind
beschäftigen und das haben wir als Team
des Museums unter der neuen Führung auch
in Zukunft vor der Direktor ich darf Sie
um einen Vortrag bitten
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren ich darf
mich zunächst einmal bedanken bedanken
für die einleitenden Worte aber bedanken
auch für zahlreiche Erscheinen
das ist mir eine große Freude und es ist
mir auch eine Ehre und mehreren Gründen
zum einen ist es emotional so etwas wie
der Beginn meiner neuen Tätigkeit im
Team des heeresgeschichtlichen Museums
zum anderen auch das
heeresgeschichtlichen Museum in befindet
sich in einer Phase der
Weiterentwicklung das ist der Dialog
sehr sehr wichtig und Ihr zahlreiches
Erscheinen zeigt uns
wie relevant das Museum ist und das auch
dieser Dialog gelebt wird danke dafür
ich darf das aber auch nutzen um auf
eine Gruppe besonders hinzuweisen die
heute hier ist diese Gruppe ist von
hoher Bedeutung weil wir im
jahresgeschichtlichen Museum in Zukunft
auch sehr sehr eng mit dem
österreichischen Bundesheer uns
verzahnen werden und es sind hier heute
unter uns und Thomas Reichel hat vorhin
schon erwähnt
informationsoffiziere die heute hier zum
ersten Kurs gehören
die ausgebildet werden im Bereich der
demokratischen Identität
die haben heute hier einen ersten Kurs
absolviert ich glaube das ist ein
Meilenstein auch weil ein Teil dieses
Kurses bei unserem jahresgeschichtliche
Museum stattfindet und wir uns hier
beschäftigen mit den Fragen von
historischen Bewusstsein
meine Damen und Herren ich habe heute
ein Thema gewählt für meinen Vortrag
dass aus trauriger Weise durchaus
Aktualitätsbezug hat seit dem russischen
Überfall auf die Ukraine müssen wir uns
wieder die Frage stellen wie wirken
Kriege auf Gesellschaft
wie werden Krieger wie wird Gewalt
verarbeitet was macht das mit einer
Gesellschaft das ist eine hochaktuelle
Frage
ich habe mir dazu das Thema Bombenkrieg
ausgewählt ich habe es unter den Titel
gestellt tot aus der Luft und ich werde
jetzt es nicht nur nach militärischen
Gesichtspunkten analysieren sondern mir
ist ganz wichtig hier diese
gesellschaftliche Wirkung hervorzukehren
auch den verarbeitungsmechanismus in
einer Gesellschaft gerade was den
Bombenkrieg betrifft
beginnen wir diese Thematik indem ich
ihnen Bilder vor Augen führe und ich bin
mir sicher dass jede und jeder Einzelne
von ihnen mit diesen Bildern sofort den
Bombenkrieg des Zweiten Weltkrieges in
Verbindung bringt den strategischen
Luftkrieg der Westallierten gegen das
Deutsche Reich das heißt diese Bilder
und obwohl diese Bilder auch nicht alle
dieser Bilder Zeitzeugen und Zeitzeugen
so in dieser Form in der Realität auch
direkt vor Augen gestanden sind wissen
wir dennoch dass dieser Bezug vorhanden
ist auch immer Emotionen
das sagt uns dass der Bombenkrieg ganz
tief ins kollektive Gedächtnis
eingedrungen ist und es nicht nur dort
und dort sehen wir es auch der
Bombenkrieg hat Symbole hinterlassen
Herr und Zeichen hinterlassen hat Ruinen
hat Überreste hinterlassen und wir
beschäftigen uns als Gesellschaft damit
ich habe hier vielleicht nur das
durchaus plakativste Beispiel in Dresden
dem Liebeskind Installation im
militärhistorischen Museum in Dresden
vorangestellt dass er so eine
Beschäftigung mit dem Bombenkrieg unter
anderem ist aber wir sehen uns überall
auch in Wien an mehreren Stellen man
kann also durchaus sagen dieser
Bombenkrieg ist ein prägendes eigenes
gewesen das und das nehme ich meinem
Vortrag durchaus schon jetzt vorweg
eine offene Wunde in der Gesellschaft
ist auch über Generationen
ich werde diese diesen Teil beleuchten
mit drei Fragen die ich jetzt versuche
auch zu beantworten erste Frage welche
Rolle hat der Bombenkrieg in der
gesellschaftlichen Wahrnehmung von Krieg
Gewalt aber letztlich auch von
Herrschaft gespielt dass die Frage
verbunden wie wird diese Form des
Krieges verarbeitet und letztlich die
Folgewirkung welche und es nämlich den
zugehörigen Begriff der Gedächtnisorte
sind dadurch entstanden und welche Rolle
spielen die bis heute in der allgemeinen
gesellschaftlichen Diskussion zu Krieg
und Gewalt
ich werde jetzt anhand von so vier
Kernpunkten und zu analysieren zunächst
einmal auf den frühen Luftkrieg eingehen
und mir die Frage stellen wie kam es
dazu dass man Gesellschaft das
Kriegsziel definiert dann den
strategischen Bombenkrieg mit der Frage
der Moral die hier eine sehr große Frage
war in den Krieg und auch vor allem
danach
und aus diesen beiden Elementen heraus
Schädeln wieder Nationalsozialisten
Nationalsozialismus mit dieser Thematik
umgegangen ist die Frage von NS
Herrschaft unterbunden ist hier zentral
und daraus dann die Gedächtnis des Kurse
ableiten damit gewissermaßen den Schwung
den Sprung in die Zeit nach dem Krieg
bis in die Gegenwart hineinnehmen bevor
ich dann zu einer Conclusio komme
beginnen wir mit dem ersten Punkt mit
dem frühen Luftkrieg und der Frage der
Gesellschaft das Kriegsziel
der Luft kriegen 1918 ist ein Produkt
einer sehr rasanten Entwicklung im
ersten weltkriegt dieser vor allem gegen
Ende des Ersten Weltkrieges sehr an
Schwung aufgenommen hat es hat sich sehr
rasch entwickelt weil wir bedenken dass
um die Jahrhundertwende Ballon
Luftschiffe Truppen noch noch in der
Entwicklung waren und haben wir am Ende
des Ersten Weltkrieges bereits einen
ersten Ansatz von strategischen
Luftangriffen auf Großstädter allen
voran London etwas
das heißt wir haben einen völlig neuen
Kriegsschauplatz der sich also im Ersten
Weltkrieg entwickelt der von besonderer
Bedeutung ist den Krieg ist nicht länger
an eine Frontlinie gebunden sondern
erreicht das Hinterland erreicht die
gesamte Gesellschaft
und das wichtig zu sehen in diesem
ersten strategischen Ansatz der also
hier vorhanden ist wird man sich damals
Gesellschaft imaginiert man hat sich
vorgestellt das Gesellschaft ein
lebendiger Organismus ist und daraus
resultiert die Vorstellung dass wenn man
diesen Organismus
in irgendeiner Art und Weise
beeinträchtigt und einen Druck aussetzt
dass dieser Organismus in Panik
verfallen könnte
wie man sich das vorgestellt hat da gab
es auch durchaus Beispiele London ist
ein sehr gutes Beispiel und sie sehen
also hier rechts unten das Bild wo das
verarbeitet wird die Flucht der Londoner
Bevölkerung in die Tunnels der London
auch in mehreren Bildern die sie hier
auch sehen also tatsächlich wirklich die
Vorstellung einer Massenpanik in London
gab es Beispiele das hat dazu geführt
dass man daraus natürlich abgeleitet hat
dass dieses psychologische Element eine
Gesellschaft so weit bringen kannte dass
sie letztlich keine Fähigkeit zu
Kriegsführung nicht mehr haben könnte
das hat man das hat man den Bombenkrieg
von Beginn an auf den Luftkrieg mit
einem narrativ und einer Propaganda
ergänzt um die Wahrnehmung zu verstärken
ein Element davon es war so etwa im im
Umfeld der Gotha und Zeppelin Angriffe
auf London war das Fische der Baby
Killers der German Baby Killers das also
damit aufgekommen ist und das Emotionen
ansprechen sollte
insgesamt
Luftkrieg war nicht voll entwickelt 1918
das heißt er hat Vorahnungen erzeugt
Vorahnung eines kommenden Krieges und
diese Vorhand genommen haben sich so
massiv gesteigert dass es auch Visionen
entstanden sind die wir vielleicht am
ersten noch mit der Angst vor der
Atombombe nach 1945 vergleichen können
auch in Österreich und in Österreich
ungarischen Kontext gab es hier konkrete
Beispiele ein eigenes ist hier besonders
bregend vielleicht nicht zeitgenössisch
prägend aber danach in der Rezeption ist
das eigenes ist der Flug von Gabriele
dann nun Wien am 9 august 1918 sie sehen
also hier eine Luftaufnahme
dieses Ereignis ist und Sie sehen das
Flugblätter italienische Flugblätter
abgeworfen worden über die Innenstadt
von Wien das wurde mir die halt
thematisiert in Österreich Ungarn
zunächst durchaus auf der humoristischen
Seite also das Italiener in dem Fall ist
keine Bomben abgeworfen sondern eben nur
Flugblätter sehr rasch hat man aber
erkannt dass hier ein Traum entstanden
ist wiederum genau an dieser Frage was
wäre gewesen wann das keine Flugblätter
werden sondern Bomben über der
Innenstadt von Wien es war niemand
vorbereitet also diese Angst die hier
entstanden ist die wird weit getragen
und wir werden es in meinem Vortrag wenn
ich immer wieder auf diesen dann nimmt
zurückkommen und zu zeigen was ich hier
letztlich an Ängsten durchaus auch
entwickelt hat
was kam aus dem ersten Weltkrieg heraus
so diese Vorahnung eines kommenden
Krieges wurde im verpackt das vor allem
auf der militärischen Seite in Luft
kriegst Theorien da gab es also etliche
also vor allem ein angekommen
amerikanischen Raum wurde das
weiterentwickelt
besonders stark und vielleicht der
bekannteste kam aus dem italienischen
Raum Julio
der hier mit dem Buch Luftherrschaft in
der deutschen Übersetzung
1920er Jahren sowas wie ein Meilenstein
geschaffen hat Meilenstein für die
weitere Entwicklung nicht im Positiven
erst definiert das Luft Krieg ein
kommender Luftkrieg die einzige Form
einer Kriegsführung sein würde die noch
von relevant ist dass alle anderen
Formen eines bodenkriegers nur noch
sekundär werden daraus wieder abgeleitet
dass der kommende Krieg sich vollständig
gegen eine Gesellschaft richten wird
und das lässt sich das Ziel eines
Luftkrieges die Ausrottung meiner
gegnerischen Gesellschaft oder
zumindestens das paralysieren einer
Gesellschaft sein müssen daraus kann man
ableiten und das wurde durch Großmächte
abgeleitet dass man strategische
bomberkräfte aufbauen müsste um ihren
erstschlagfähigkeit zu erzielen
man kann aber auch daraus ableiten das
wurde gemacht vor allem in
österreichischen Kontext dass man eine
Gesellschaft auf einen kommenden Krieg
vorbereiten muss der zweite Aspekt wie
gesagt eingepackt in horoszenarien wurde
wirklich breit rezipiert auf mehreren
Ebenen ist heute noch präsent mit den
Luft kriegst Theorien
probieren wir das ein wenig
aufzuschlüsseln auch was zu je definiert
hat das ist angesprochen hat und es muss
müssen wir sehr deutlich sagen wenn wir
sein Werk betrachten dann hat er hier
einen Krieg zwischen zwei
Industriestaaten definiert auch zwischen
zwei Großmächten und daraus abgeleitet
das also dieser kommende Luft Krieg
nicht stattfinden wird aufgrund eines
Gleichgewichts des Schreckens wir kennen
das wiederum von der Atombombe so sehr
ähnlich in der Zwischenkriegszeit also
erst und zweitschlagfähigkeit waren hier
die wichtigsten Themen
wesentlich weniger thematisiert hat die
das Verhältnis zwischen einer Großmacht
und den Staaten vor allem Mitteleuropa
wo so keine Großmacht vorhanden waren
Staaten wie Deutschland oder Österreich
natürlich nicht die Fähigkeit hatten
eine militärische defensivkapazität
aufzubauen
daraus hat sich auch in diesen Staaten
besonders stark abgeleitet wiederum die
Bevölkerung auf einen Krieg
vorzubereiten
was du je weniger definiert also andere
definieren ist welche Situation haben
wir
wenn es kein Krieg zwischen zwei großen
Mächten oder zwei Industriestaaten ist
sondern wenn wir hier von einem nicht
industrialisierten Staat sprechen oder
wenn wir von einer Kolonie sprechen und
hier sind gewissermaßen da wo man vorher
noch Gleichgewicht erschrecken hatten
das Gleichgewicht des Schreckens hat ja
auch dazu geführt dass man sich überlegt
hat wo haben wir moralische Grenzen also
was sollten wir tun was was wäre noch
legitim aus moralischer Hinsicht das
Überlegungen gibt es im Bereich der
Kolonien eigentlich nicht
und dieses vor allem Hugh change hat und
Großbritannien dass das entwickelt
Formen von
airpoding oder control with the
occupation das sind Reaktionen auch auf
den ersten Weltkrieg das heißt das
Großbritannien waren also in dieser Form
nicht mehr fähig alles eine Kolonien
militärisch zu kontrollieren und hier
die Überlegung mit Flugzeugen Herrschaft
auszuüben also dieses diesen Schrecken
den Flugzeuge ausstrahlen letztlich dazu
zu nutzen um eine Kontrolle über einen
Staat auszuüben das wurde also hier ganz
gezielt wir sehen hier Bilder vom Irak
etwa auch in Indien gab es diese Formen
später hat es auch in Italien ganz
massiv angewandt
das ist eine andere Form die da hier
weniger mit diskutiert wird
wir sind Österreich ausgesehen hier ist
es vor allem sind Personen werden
Alexander Löhr der also die ersten
Luftkräfte geprägt hat er wieder dann im
Zweiten Weltkrieg eine Wiener gerümliche
Rolle spielen
der aber von Anfang an in diese
Vorbereitung der umfassenden
luftkriegsführung was Österreich nicht
fähig gewesen wäre eine strategische
Komponente aufzubauen
sofortüberlegung eingebaut hat eben
diese Vorbereitung der Gesellschaft auf
einen kommenden Luftkrieg und das mit
dem Bereich und einem Begriff Luftschutz
das ist etwas das liegt auf der Hand
auch luftschutzgemeinschaften die also
gegründet wurden wir müssen uns vor
Augen führen dass das Vereinigungen
waren mit Millionen Mitgliedern auch aus
der Angst heraus entstanden ist
und in diesen luftschutzorganisationen
ging es letztlich darum die Erziehung
der Gesellschaft hin zu einem Krieg und
wir müssen uns auch klar sein also mit
der Frage Moral ja
alles anders gedacht nämlich fast im
Bereich der Resilienz also wie
widerstandsfähig ist eine Gesellschaft
das war eine Schlagworte damals und wir
müssen uns vor Augen führen dass das
Potenzial das hier geschaffen wurde
diese Millionen starken Vereine
eigentlich natürlich auch ein System der
Kontrolle sind da hat man einen Teil der
Bevölkerung unter Kontrolle und das
wurde in dieser Formen 30er Jahren noch
massiv ausgeübt das war in Österreich
der Fall es war dann auch im
nationalsozialistischen Deutschland in
dieser Form der Fall
sie sehen übrigens auch hier das darf
ich noch anmerken ganz links außen
wiederum das alte der nuncio also der
Flug über Wien
verbunden in dem Fall sie sind Gas über
Österreich
verbunden mit der nächsten Uhr Angst aus
dem ersten Weltkrieg heraus nämlich den
Einsatz von Gas und sie sehen wie stark
dieses der nuncio im österreichischen
Kontext weitergewirkt hat es wird immer
wieder thematisiert
die wohl stärkste Beschäftigung fand in
den 30er Jahren ganz allgemein statt und
sie wissen natürlich auch vom Einsatz
der
von Deutschland auch im spanischen
Bürgerkrieg in der Legion Condor und
daraus natürlich den Luftangriff auf
qrnika und das was sie also hier am
Gemälde von Picasso sehen zu werden kann
als einer der Beschäftigung mit dem
Luftkrieg in dieser Zeit und mit den
Schrecken die also im Luftangriffe wie
Guericke ausgelöst haben auch mit den
gesamten Horrorvisionen die damit
verbunden waren das Gemälde drückte sehr
sehr deutlich aus also wie auch die
Gefühlslage die emotionslager letztlich
dann in den 30er Jahren der Fall
warnika und und natürlich auch der
spanische Bürgerkrieg sind Testfälle in
dem Fall für die deutsche Luftwaffe für
einen kommenden Luft kriegt das macht es
für mich natürlich die Frage auf
wie hat der Nationalsozialismus diesen
kommenden Luftkrieg thematisiert und da
darf ich einen Blick wagen zum Chef
Ideologen der NSDAP zur alfred Rosenberg
der 1930 in seinem Werk der Mythos
formuliert hat und ich zitiere der
Bombenkrieg ist ein Geschenk
daher das uralte organische Verhältnis
zwischen Volk und Krieg wieder herstellt
dass das ganze Volk teilnehmen muss am
Kampf um sein da sein Zitat Ende das hat
mir eine Wort für den
Nationalsozialismus war völlig klar wie
dieser kommende Luftkrieg aussehen wird
und dass er sich massiv auch gegen
deutsche Luft gegen deutsche Städte
richten wird daraus abgeleitet in einer
perfiden Logik
das genau das also je stärker die
Gesellschaft von Zerstörung Tod und
Schrecken betroffen ist umso mehr wird
sie kämpfen umso weniger wird sie Regime
und die Notwendigkeit zu Krieg Führung
in Frage stellen das ist die Befehle
Logik dahinter und so geht der
Nationalsozialismus in den Zweiten
Weltkrieg
es ist das damals schon definiert das
Konzept eines Volks Kriegers das was man
dann später auch als totaler Krieg
bezeichnet wird
nehmen wir das Anlass um es den Schritt
weiter zu gehen also innenstrategischen
Bomben Krieg hinein
im Anfang schon Bilder gezeigt ich darf
das hier wieder tun das strategische
Luftkrieg hat sich schrittweise
entwickelt also eine Eskalation heraus
nehmen wir Deutsche Luftangriffe sie
sehen also hier ein Bild von
rotterdamenangriffer Warschau dann auch
auf Belgrad unter anderem auch britische
Städte in Reaktion darauf dann Angriffe
auf deutsche Städte und dieses ständige
Aufschaukeln was immer mehr Grenzen
gefallen sind und auch Hemmschwellen
gefallen sind ab 1941 oder ab 1940 und
dann vor allem verstärkt 1941 ist dann
Luftkrieg für Großbritannien und dann ab
41 auch für die USA
die einzige militärische Möglichkeit um
auf Festland Europa noch einzuwirken
insofern nimmt also das strategische
Luft kriegt dann sofort auf und damit
verbunden ist immer die Frage der
Beeinträchtigung des Gegners und auf
mehreren Ebenen also Überlegung wo kann
man das Deutsche Reich so stark treffen
das ist die Fähigkeit zu Kriegsführung
verliert und das schließt allerdings
auch die Bevölkerung mit ein
wird sich nun dieser Luftkrieg
entwickelt er war schrittweise und ich
dafür nur ein paar Punkte nennen wo das
vielleicht relevant ist das erste
tausend Bombe Angriff auf Köln 1942
diese erste Schockwirkung
wir haben dann im Frühjahr 43 ganz
massiv die ruheoffensive und dann sehen
wir wie dieser Luftkrieg sie stetig nach
Osten ausweitert also das heißt nach der
ruheoffensive Angriffe auch auf
staudämmer kam am 25 Juli der Beginn der
sogenannten Operation gomora das heißt
der Luft der schweren Luftangriffe auf
Hamburg und den fachung eines
Feuersturms das war die größte
luftkriegs-katastrophe des Zweiten
Weltkrieges hat auch Dresden bei weitem
überschritten
in dieser Zensur und ich erwähnen sie
deswegen so besonders zum einen weil sie
Wellen der Angst durch das Deutsche
Reich gejagt hat allein die Vorstellung
dass er so ist westallierte fähig sind
dazu eine Großstadt im Grunde
auszulöschen
fällt noch wesentlicher als Zensur ist
das in diesem Moment das in es Regime
realisiert hat dass man auf diesen Ruf
Krieg mit allen verhandelnden Mitteln
reagieren mussten dass es keine
militärischen Mittel dagegen mehr gibt
diese Erkenntnis kann nicht nur mit
Hamburg sondern zeitgleich
auch mit der Ausweitung des luftkriegers
von Nordafrika und von Italien aus auch
auf den Alpenraum damit auf das heutige
Österreich parallel das heißt auch die
Vorstellung dahinter stand ganz
eindeutig der Versuch die Kräfte der
deutschen Luftwaffe zu überdehnen hat
natürlich im Deutschen Reich das Signal
aus gesamt aus im Grunde kein Bereich
des Deutschen Reiches mehr sicher von
Luftangriffen ist das hat sich dann
Städte gesteigert gegen Ende 43 dann
auch auf Berlin das reagiert dann Joseph
Goebbels mit seiner NS-Propaganda und
dann in weiterer Folge und ich habe hier
einen weiteren traurigen Höhepunkt es
ist Dresden natürlich im Februar 1945
wie schaut es für den österreichischen
Kontext aus auch da hier ganz kurz an
einem Beispiel gezeigt auch wie sich
diese Luft kriegen entwickelt wir sehen
also am 13 August 1943 den ersten
Luftangriff der Wiener Neustadt trifft
hier vor allem auf die Industrie im 25
Februar 44 beginnt die Quick Angriff auf
die Luftwaffe und das steigert sich und
ab Oktober 1944 können wir von täglichen
einflügen in den Alpenraum sprechen
warum erwähne ich diese schrittweise
jetzt auch weil sie hier sehen und das
ist also vor allem in Luft kriegt
Amerikaner der 15 US Army Air Force im
Alpenraum die Suche nach Zielsystemen
nach sogenannten bei einer Fiat targets
also
Zielsystemen die relevant fürs gesamtes
System sind das ist zunächst die
Industrie das funktioniert nicht auch
den Angriff auf die deutsche Luftwaffe
funktioniert nicht das was funktioniert
ja vieles Verse des Deutschen Reiches
ist Öl und Verkehr
und das ist auch das was uns beim Bomben
kriegt bis heute in Erinnerung ist
Angriff auf die Verkehrslinien und damit
auf die Hauptbahnhöfe weil deswegen
trifft die Städte
sie sehen also hier eine Luftaufnahme
von diesem ersten Angriff auf Wiener
Neustadt
Aufnahmen die sich die sich hier in dem
Fall teilweise geschossen als
amerikanischen Bomben zeigen also Graz
und der Bombenhagel oder auch
Mittelfeld das bombardiert wurde Angriff
auf Öl Zügen in dem Fall auch hier zu
sehen und vielleicht auch um einen
Eindruck zu bekommen es ist ein
aufklärungsfoto von Graz von Grazer
Hauptbahnhof und Sie sehen also die
Zerstörung im Innenstadt zu einem
Stadtbereich ist natürlich schon sehr
massiv
meine Damen und Herren das was ich Ihnen
jetzt geschildert habe ja das ist also
eine Abfolge vielleicht auch eine
chronologische Abfolge des
bombenkriegers die Frage die wir uns
aber stellen müssen ist wir haben die
Menschen diesen Luftkrieg wahrgenommen
also wie ist die Wahrnehmung dieses
bombenkriegers
da müssen wir deutlich sagen auch aus
dem Forschungen heraus das ist eine
völlig neue Form des Krieges die hier
Platz greift
das heißt es liegen keine
Erfahrungswerte für die meisten Menschen
zu diesem Zeitpunkt vor keine
Erfahrungswerte bedeutet dass man das
was man erlebt nicht einordnen kann auch
nicht verarbeiten kann
dazu kommt dass die erfahrungsorte des
Bombenkrieges großteils die
Luftschutzkeller sind wo man sich
hinflüchtet
dort wiederum sind die
Sinneswahrnehmungen auf den Hörsinn
reduziert
diese Reduktion bedeutet die weitere
Reduktion auch der
einschätzungsmöglichkeiten also das was
man erlebt sirenengeräusche
Motorengeräusche fallende Bomben
ist nicht einzuschätzen in seiner
Gefährlichkeit auch in seiner weiteren
Folgewirkung schwer einzuschätzen das
verursacht Unsicherheit und Angst
und diese fehlende Informationen die man
durch die Reduktion auf das Hören hat
die Sucht nach etwas
das ist suchen findet man in
Informationsquellen sind zunächst nahe
liegend Gerüchte
halten wir uns vor Augen man tritt aus
einem Luftschutzkeller und das waren
also Fragen die die Menschen tatsächlich
bewegt haben auf die Straße sieht das
eigene Haus in Schutt und Asche liegen
und das Haus des Nachbarns völlig intakt
wie kann man sich das erklären und genau
diese Fragen betreffen die Menschen zu
diesem Zeitpunkt
relevant ist dass alles das was ich
ihnen das Schilder großes Problem für
das NES Regime ist denn die Gerüchte und
das womit die fehlende Einschätzung
letztlich gefüllt wird die Arbeiter dann
einer Säule deines Herrschaften nämlich
am vertrauen
und das definiert deine esstaat
1943 als das das zentrale ihnen
politische Problem und bearbeitet ist
auf mehreren Ebenen ich darf Ihnen um
das so wenig zu illustrieren
eine Aufnahme aus einem
Luftschutzkeller zeigen Berliner Kontext
nicht zeigen sondern hörbar machen um
ihnen zu wenig die geräuschwelten vor
Augen zu führen
[Musik]
kurz unterbrechen was da das sind
geraffter Form aber es soll
verdeutlichen wie diese Erfahrungswelten
letztlich auch in den Luftschutzkellern
Platz greifen und mich beängstigende
Wirkung das natürlich hatte
schauen wir deswegen einen Schritt
weiter und überlegen wir uns jetzt wenn
ich davon gesprochen habe dass der
Nationalsozialismus das NS-Regime dass
es das zentrale innenpolitische Problem
betrachtet
wie sah nun ein s-herrschaft unter
Bomben aus also wie reagiert er das in
es Regime genau auf diese akustischen
Welten und auf diese Einschränkung und
Reduktion der Wahrnehmung
auf mehreren Ebenen und ich darf
beginnen mit einem Sprung hier in diesen
in dieses Museum hinein aber wenn sie
anderen sind 43
hier wurde im Frühjahr 1943 eine
Ausstellung konzipiert und in weiterer
Folge auch gezeigt unter dem Titel der
Luft Terror
sie wurde hier konzipiert das
Wanderausstellung und sollte und es
zitiere ich direkt daraus
die Ausstellung gegen den lufttärer die
in Wien gleichzeitig an fünf Stellen
gezeigt wird verfolgt den Zweck jenen
Volksgenossen die den luftterer noch
nicht aus eigenem Erlebnis kennen
ein anschauliches Bild seiner Wirkungen
seiner Gefahren zu geben das Ziel hinter
dieser Ausstellung also mit einem Wortes
Regime geht im Frühjahr 1943 sie
erinnern sich im August der erste
Angriff im Alpenraum also Monate davor
dazu über den Menschen im Alpenraum den
Luftkrieg in einem anderen Gebiet vor
Augen zu führen
das klingt das hier noch sehr harmlos
also auf die Gefahren hinzuweisen
tatsächlich hat man wesentlich mehr als
das getan
schau mal rein was konkret Geschehnisse
sehen hier eine Aufnahme die in dieser
Ausstellung gezeigt wird seine Aufnahme
aus Mailand das heißt man hat also in
einer Fotoausstellung die Luftangriffe
sichtbar gemacht
in italienischen Städten also klarer
Bezug ist man wollte etwas erzielen aber
den connects nicht zu eng ziehen
deswegen italienischen Städte nicht die
Deutschen
[Musik]
den Bildern wenn wir uns nur die
Bildsprache anschauen die sie sehen sie
sind wieder Menschen auf den Straßen
also das Signal ist ja wir haben Luft
aber das wird bewältigt durch die
Menschen also der Blickrichtung
Gesellschaft
auch sehen ganz deutlich ist Schäden
wenn man nachweisen wollte dass ich
dieser Bombenkrieg gegen die Kulturgüter
riecht hat also das ist ein
unzivilisierter Angriff ist das heißt
ein ganz klares vereinsbild das damit
ein weiterer Folge aufgebaut wurde
in dieser Ausstellung waren auch Teile
von abgestürzten Flugzeugen zu sehen das
Sieg über den Feind und es wurde zu
Vergeltung aufgerufen Teile aus dieser
Ausstellung befinden sich noch heute im
jahresgeschichtliche Museum in der
Sammlung also das heißt das ist durchaus
nachhaltig gewesen
wie schauen nun die reaktionsebenen aus
und ich darf Ihnen hier vier Ebenen ganz
kurz durch skizzieren die erste Ebene
das liegt irgendwo auf der Hand und wir
haben es aus der Zwischenkriegszeit
heraus natürlich auch schon gesehen
Luftschutz und Opferhilfe das ist
natürlich naheliegend
dass man hier sofort Maßnahmen setzt zum
einen in der Prävention also Luftschutz
die Menschen vorzubereiten in den
Schutzmöglichkeiten zu geben und
Opferhilfe als auf das danach nach
Luftangriffen zu gehen
der Punkt ist wenn wir uns anschauen wie
ab 19 spätestens ab 1943 wie viel
Ressourcen das in hessischen darin
aufgewandt hat dann sieht man dass es
natürlich wesentlich weiter darüber
hinausgeht über diese ursprüngliche
Wirkung die Partei war nach
Luftangriffen auf der Stelle Präsident
sichtbar sein
das Prinzip war was dort anzuleiten wo
man Hilfe leistet das heißt man wollte
dass die betroffenen Menschen sich
gegenseitig helfen das ist das Ziel
gewesen
Punkte ist auch im Luftschutz stark
unter Kontrolle der Partei die
bunkerwarte als aus Symbol dass man sie
heute noch was sagt das ist heute noch
ein Begriff die Vorsicht die man in
Luftschutzkeller walten lassen musste
was was man spricht bei mitgehört wird
ganz relevant und das wird glaube ich in
der Debatte zum Luftschutz viel zu wenig
thematisiert ist das all das was ich
jetzt gezielt habe und was uns logische
scheint Hilfe Schutz an regime-konformes
Verhalten gekoppelt war das heißt man
konnte Hilfe und Schutz auch entziehen
und das geschah auch das geschah auf
einer
konkreten Ebene nämlich bei den Gegnern
des Nationalsozialismus das begann bei
KZ insassenen und Insassen setzte sich
fort bei Zwangsarbeiterinnen und
Zwangsarbeitern
die durften während der Luftangriffe
keine Luftschutzkeller aufsuchen
die mussten also Luftangriffe im Freien
leben und überleben
das geschah auch mit Personen die man
aus der Volksgemeinschaft ausschließt
weil sie Gerüchte verbreitet hatten zum
Beispiel es reichte dann schon weil sie
sich kritisch geäußert haben es war eine
Strafmaßnahme sie aus diesen Maßnahmen
auszuschließen
sie sehen also hier dass ein Beispiel ja
dass man das auch etwas ein Gerüchte
verbreitern also diejenigen die genau in
dem Segment arbeiten wo die
Informationen fehlen also wo die
Gerüchte entstehen dass man dann auch
die Schuld dafür gab das einzelne Häuser
getroffen wurden
gegenüber plünder ran und sage ich jetzt
das wurde es ja sehr sehr eng gefasst da
reichten Winzigkeiten dass man aus einem
Brotstück aufhob nach einem Luftangriff
aus den Trümmern konnte schon dazu
führen dass man zum Tode verurteilt
wurde weil das Regime genau in diesem
Segment ganz ganz konkret gearbeitet hat
das ging auch über die zweite also wenn
ich jetzt davon spreche dass die das
hier das Regime arbeitet dann sehen wir
das noch einmal deutlich nämlich was war
das Ziel
war die betroffene Bevölkerung in ihrer
Rolle zu definieren als Gemeinschaft
nicht dafür zitieren die Aussage von
einem Zeitzeugen Wilfried ffn
anonymisiert ich zitiere beim Bomben
Terror da gab es echten Zusammenhalt und
eine Gemeinschaft der half jeder jeden
der Stand niemand daneben auch die
Partei war immer da Zitat Ende
sehen wir uns heute Erinnerungen an den
Bombenkrieg an dann ist diese
Gemeinschaft und diese Hilfe in der
Luftschutzkeller noch immer äußerst
positiv besetzt und äußerst stark
vorhanden als kernerativ
dahinter steckt nichts anderes als ein
gemeinschaftskonstrukt des Regimes das
hat man darüber dann auch
Begrifflichkeiten der bunkergemeinschaft
gelegt die waren ziemlich abgeschlossen
meistens zu einem Häuserblock dass man
dann strikt darauf geachtet dass er hier
in diese Gemeinschaft niemand eindringt
niemand fremder auch
Schicksalsgemeinschaft also die Idee
diese Schrecken und diese Angst die man
jetzt nicht alleine zu erleiden sondern
gemeinsam und damit leichter zu machen
sondern Sozialismus ist aber hergegangen
und diese Gemeinschaften in zunehmenden
Maße militärisch definiert
der Begriff des Kämpfers im Luftschutz
was bedeutet das konkretes sind also
hier rechts ein Plakat mit Göring der
das also direkt thematisiert
was aber auch sehen ist sind gefallen in
einen Anzeigen in Zeitungen im
Tageszeitungen das wirkt für uns absolut
befremdlich und vielleicht auch völlig
unverständlich dass man nach einem
Luftangriff
gewissermaßen die tragischen
dramatischen Folgen eines Angriffs so
sichtbar macht nämlich mit seitenlernen
Todesanzeigen das muss für die Menschen
erschütternd gewesen sein sowas zu sehen
nach einem Luftangriff die Wirkung
dessen war aber wichtiger nämlich den
Tod einen Sinn zu geben und das sind
bedeutet ganz eindeutig und sie sehen
das Eiserne Kreuz hier drauf und auch
die Bezeichnungen der Kämpfer sie als
militärische Opfer zu definieren
das ging so weit und sie sehen also hier
eine Aufnahme aus dem Grazer Landhaus
die Beisetzung von bombendoten mit
militärischen Ehren durch die Wehrmacht
und durch die Luftwaffe ging so weit
dass man einzelne Bomben tote
tatsächlich in einzelnen Städten auch
der Kirche wieder ein zog also kein
kirchliches Begräbnis sondern ein
militärisches also ganz klar deutlich
zugeordnet
behalten wir diese militärische
Definition wenig im Hinterkopf bei
meiner weiteren Ausführungen
also die dritte Ebene die dritte Ebene
war die Deutung des Luftkrieges also das
was man jetzt direkt erlebte und das
sind wir genau in einem Segment da wo
die Menschen es nicht einschätzen können
dort ist jetzt die NS-Propaganda
hineingegangen
und hat begonnen zunächst einmal das
begann
41 42 da war die kernerzählung der
NS-Propaganda das ist ein Angriff auf
die Kulturgüter wäre also die die Idee
dahinter ist der Erzählung das Deutsche
Reich als Kulturnation und dagegen hat
der ist dieses Deutsche Reich angreift
ist eine nicht ein nicht zivilisierter
Staat das ist die kleinerzählung der hat
man dann so Begriffe zugeordnet wie Luft
hungern und das noch weiter zu
verdeutlichen
Tagebuch anfang 1943 auch deutlich
markiert und immer gesagt hat das wirkt
überhaupt nicht also das wirkt viel zu
wenig stark das verfasste Emotionen der
Menschen nicht
und deswegen beginnt man ab dieser
ruheoffensive und dann ganz stark ab dem
Beginn des Luftangriffs auf Hamburg
damit eine völlig andere Seite zu
beleuchten unter dem Stichwort Bomben
Terror das heißt diesen luftkriegers
Verbrechen zu definieren
als Krieg gegen die Zivilbevölkerung und
das versieht man auch emotional mit
Erzählung und mit der Begrifflichkeit
des Kindermordes
in diesem Moment wird es auch
Verwaltungssprache das heißt es durften
Luftangriffe nicht nur Luftangriffe
genannt werden in der Verwaltungssprache
sondern nur noch Terrorangriffe oder
Kindermord
die Bildwelten dazu wurden entsprechend
inszeniert es wurden Ausstellungen ich
habe das also für den für den Wiener
Raum schon zitiert gemacht Reportagen
Bildberichte
videoberichter es wurde alles aufgebaut
und diese Erzählung letztlich zu
schützen Ziel weiß
durch den es Regime das informational
und das wirft das automatisch und ich
habe das schon gesagt wenn wir über das
sprechen dann wirft das auch die Frage
der vorhandenen Bildwelten auf da müssen
wir uns das Historik immer sehr sehr
bewusst sein was das bedeutet
es gab ein ganz klares Verbot für
private Aufnahmen im
bombardierungsgebieten das stand auch
sogar an der Todesstrafe das heißt die
Bildwelten die uns heute zur Verfügung
stehen vom bombardierten Städten die
sind aus den Linsen der NS-Propaganda
geschossen das bedeutet nicht dass die
Schrecken deswegen weniger gewesen wären
oder die Zerstörungen aber wir müssen
uns bewusst sein welche Bildsprache sie
haben warum sie in dieser Form gezeigt
werden und warum sind dieser in dieser
Form auch vorliegen es muss uns bewusst
sein heute dass diese Bildwelten ganz
gezielt eingesetzte Bildwelten waren
es bringt mich zum vierten everne wenn
wir so darüber sprechen die Bevölkerung
die betroffen ist als
Komponenten zu definieren beinahe es
Kämpfer den Luft kriegt zu
kriminalisieren dann ist natürlich die
nächste Frage ja was passiert mit dem
Protagonisten der Luftangriffe
auch hier gab es Überlegungen der
Propaganda das war zunächst
bis 1942 die Zählung der gegnerische
Stadt die Blutung ist es die diese
Bombenangriffe letztlich einleitet und
auch angeordnet hat
dahinter steht also wieder diese
Begrifflichkeit des Angriffs auf
Kulturgüter
auch das wirkt wirkt der überhaupt nicht
konkret ab 1943 und hier ganz gezielt ab
Hamburg beginnt auch hier eine völlig
andere schieneplatz zu greifen nämlich
die Kriminalisierung der
Flugzeugbesatzungen die man jetzt auch
nicht mehr als Flugzeugbesatzungen
bezeichnen durfte sondern nur noch als
Terrorflieger
da gab es ein konkretes Beispiel dass
sie hier links sehen das ist die
Geschichte von Latein und keiner
Williams der im November 1943 bei Bremen
abgeschossen wurde
sehen Sie auf der Aufnahme am Rücken von
seiner Bomberjacke fand sich der
Schriftzug Mörder ink Mörder in
corporated das ist der Name seines
Flugzeugs der Name war selbst gewählt
von der Besatzung natürlich nicht
sonderlich geschickt gewählt spielt mit
diesem Mafia Begriff
der Punkt ist die Aufnahme von ihm ist
nicht ohne Grund in der Zeitung
eine Initiative gestartet sein Bild wo
in allen Tageszeitungen über Monate
hinweg abgedruckt das wurden Privatdaten
von ihm in die Zeitungen gestellt
Familienangehörige Freunde Wohnort und
dergleichen mehr und die kernerzählung
aufgestellt dass die Amerikaner Gangster
aus Chicago rekrutieren und ganz gezielt
deutsche Frauen und Kinder zu ermorden
also ganz stark auf Emotion umgesetzte
Erzählung ziel des Ganzen war auf ein
greifbares Feindbild also einen
abgeschossenen Flieger Wut und
zueinander Bevölkerung in den
bombardierungsgebieten zu kanalisieren
also ein greifbares Feindbild zu geben
damit dieser Wut und 20 nicht gegen das
Regime Richters
die Folge war dramatisch und wenn sie
Tageszeitungen aufschlagen aus dieser
Zeit dann werden sie deutlich sehen wie
ab November Dezember 1943 auch die
Berichterstattung sich zu Beginn zu
wandeln es wurden abgeschossene
Flugzeugbesatzungen auch in demütigen
Positionen gezeigt auch die Leichname
von abgeschossenen Flugzeugbesatzungen
die furchtbar zugerichtet waren wurden
öffentlich zu Schau gestellt in
Zeitungen abgedruckt also es war ein
ganz klares Bild das hier vermittelt
wurde mehr noch als das
kam daraus auch etwas anderes heraus man
hat sich noch im Dezember 1943 überlegt
wie reagiert man es auf diesen keiner
Williams und auf Mörder ink
hat zunächst einmal überlegt
Schauprozesse durchzuführen davon kann
man wieder ab weil sie nicht wirkt im
Sinne dessen was das in estream vor
hatte und beschloss im Frühjahr 1944
einen anderen Schritt und sie sehen Sie
einen Akten gezeichnet in dem Fall von
Alfred Jodl die Überlegung wie soll das
Verfahren sein durch das Volk oder durch
die Dienststellen also die Überlegung
hier ganz gezielt Maßnahmen zu setzen
im Mai 44 legt man fest dass das ab nun
die lünenjustiz das Regeln hat
ganz wesentlich daran ist für uns heute
das ist der Blick hinein in die
Funktionsweise den es Herrschaft das ist
kein du musst Gewalt anwenden das ist
kein Befehl zu Gewalt es ist eine
Freigabe von Gewalt es ist ein du kannst
das verstanden werden sollte als du
sollst
weil es im Sinne ist die Folgen sind
dramatisch ich darf Ihnen hier nur ein
paar
grafische und und
lässt sich auch Zahlen zur Verfügung
stellen bei knapp 600 Flugzeugabstürzen
im österreichischen im heutigen
österreichischen Raum in einem Zeitraum
von eineinhalb Jahren
konnten wir bisher 101 mordefest sein
die kaum bekannt sind also tatsächlich
Formen und noch immer 113 vermisste
Flugzeugbesatzungen nach denen auch noch
aktiv gesucht wird durch das USS
departner auf defense
ich will gar nicht zu stark auf die
lünejustiz eingehen das ist durchaus
Forschungsthema nämlich mich gewidmet
habe das wäre ein eigener Vortrag ich
möchte hier und das ist mir sehr wichtig
auch durchaus mit Blick auf das
jahresgeschichtliche Museum Menschen zu
Wort kommen lassen und das darf ich auch
in diesem Fall tun und und hier den
Bericht eines Überlebenden bringen
dieser Lynchjustiz es ist Latein und
Herold braun das KI geärmen ein Affe
amerikanischer Flieger der Betrieben im
14 märz 1945 abgeschossen wurde
[Musik]
okay
bei Meisterschaften
das kurz zusammenzufassen von der
Situation in trieben also so etwas 30
Personen auf ihn zu gestürmt sind und im
deutlich das Zeichen gegeben und das
sind Orden wollen und das ist so viel
mehr mit seinem Leben dort abgeschlossen
oder was ein Polizist der sich in dieser
Situation entschieden hat in das Leben
zu retten sicher so hinzustellen und
diese Situationen Gewalt zu durchbrechen
das soll nur so ein kleiner Hinweis sein
in welcher Dynamik solche Situationen
letztlich entstehen und auch wie die
einzelnen Entscheidungen von Personen
solche Situationen beeinflussen können
ich darf noch einmal kurz zusammenfassen
was ich in Bezug auf den Bombenkrieg
gesagt habe Bombenkrieg mit Druck auf
die Gesellschaft die also durchaus
entstand Druck aber auch in Form das ist
auf eine Säule den s-herrschaft gewirkt
hat das ein s-regime darauf reagiert
über gemeinschaftskonstrukt über eine
kriegsdeutung eine sehr scharfe
emotionale ein Feindbild und lässt sich
mit einer gewaltfreigabe gegenüber
abgeschossenen Besatzungen und das
umrahmt durch Bild weil eine ganz
gezielt geschaffen wurden was tragen
tief ins kollektive Gedächtnis sein das
bringt mich auch schon zum nächsten zum
letzten Punkt zu den gedächtniskursen
der Bombenkrieg war 1945 mit Kriegsende
überall sichtbar überall haben
hinterlassen aber fast in jeder Stadt
sichtbar und zu sehen spürbar doch
schwerste Zerstörungen war eine zentrale
kriegswahrnehmung der Menschen im Inland
des Deutschen Reiches und wurde dort
einen Nachkriegszeit auch zu einer
zentralen kriegserinnerung und dieser
Transfer von der Wahrnehmung in der
Erinnerung letztlich
geschah und mit ungebrochenen mit den
ungebrochenen
narrativens das muss man deutlich sagen
auch was die Bildwelten betrifft also
die Emotionen die da drinnen war die
blieb erhalten auch mit den
entsprechenden Deutungen
und ganz stark verankert in einer
Wahrnehmung einer gesellschaftlichen
einer gesellschaftlichen
opferwahrnehmung
mehr noch als das und das sehen wir in
der gesellschaftlichen Debatte war wurde
der Bombenkrieg auch zu einem Refugium
einer gesellschaftlichen Opfer
Wahrnehmung
auch im Gegensatz zu täterdebatten also
dort wo man sehr sehr lange die Frage
diskutiert hat Täter innerhalb des
Holocaust da wurde durchaus der
Bombenkrieg in einer anderen Form
thematisiert nämlich in Frage der Opfer
in der Zivilbevölkerung
Bombenkrieg wurde auch zu dem was man im
österreichischen Kontext die doppelte
Opfer dieser nennt und das verdeutlicht
vielleicht am besten ein Auszug aus dem
Österreich Buch des Jahres 1948 ich
zitiere Wiens bitterste Tage waren
gekommen
Bombengeschwader die Feinde der Front
die Freunde des Herzens zerstörten um
uns zu befreien also das ist diese
doppelte Opfer diese also die Frage
einerseits die Vorstellung dass man das
erste Opfer des Nationalsozialismus
geworden wäre dieser Erzählung die
Österreich aufgebaut hat jetzt erkennst
und der Erzählung dass man auch Opfer
des Krieges geworden wäre und dazu dient
der Bombenkrieg und diese Erzählung zu
untermauern
und das trank ich nur gleichzeitig in
den 50er und 60er Jahren auch ins
kultureller Gedächtnis sein und sie
sehen sind in Form von Denkmälern
vielleicht am stärksten sehen wir es in
ehemaligen bombardierungsgebieten wo
dann in die Kriegerdenkmäler auch die
Erinnerungen die bombenopfern die
zivilenbombenopfer aufgenommen wurde
es ist sehr emotionaler Schritt gewesen
ja also in der Logik der Gemeinden
erklärbar ist der weil letztendlich
genau das narrativ das ist in Österreich
im aufgebaut hat dass das nämlich
militärische Opfer werden natürlich
fortgeschrieben hat
die Diskussionen gab es aber nicht nur
im deutschen oder österreichischen
Kontext wir sehen auch in England in
England ist es festgemacht an der Art
der Harris debatter der Frage die schon
unmittelbar nach dem Luftangriff auf
Dresden gestellt wurde nämlich die Frage
der Schuld die Frage ob ein derartiger
Angriff auf eine Großstadt moralisch
legitim ist das ist das was Eingang ganz
stark diskutiert wird immer wieder und
sie sehen Sie hier rechts auch in der
Stadt von Harrys dem dem Kommentar des
Bomber Command
der auch was einziger Kommentar nicht
geehrt wurde nach Ende des Krieges
und das ist so Zeit seines Lebens immer
eine offene Wunde war zeigt sie deutlich
wie Gesellschaften sich mit dieser Form
eines Krieges letztlich
auseinandersetzen auf mehreren
in der Forschung und gehen wir wieder
zurück in den deutschen und
österreichischen Kontext ist es relativ
eindeutig sehr sehr lange bis in den
90er 2000er Jahre ist die Kernfrage der
Forschung zum Bombenkrieg war dieser
Bombenkrieg legitim oder seinen
Kriegsverbrechen das ist die Frage es
war noch ergänzt durch Chronologien
Luftangriffe also begleitend
gewissermaßen die tiefen Betrachtungen
nämlich was löst das in einer
Gesellschaft aus wie reagiert das ein
Netz Regime darauf wie ist es auch eine
Logik des Holocaust mit eingepackt all
das blieb weit das Gehen aus blieb eine
Betrachtung die man nicht die man nicht
wagt das blieb also in diesem
moralischen Betrachtungen und das löste
die Debatte rund um Dresden festgemacht
ähm dem Wunsch die genaue Opferzahl zu
definieren wollen
Kommissionen eingesetzt um die Opferzahl
ganz klar zu definieren was schwer ist
natürlich emotional besetzt und wieder
an dieser moralischen Frage festgemacht
noch deutlicher was dann gemerkt an der
sogenannten Friedrich Debatte die ich ob
ihrer Wichtigkeit hier noch einmal
gezielt herausgreifen darf
festgemacht an Jörg Friedrich der also
2001 2002 mehrere Bücher zum Bombenkrieg
herausgebracht hat eins davon
brandstätten
und da drinnen hat einen indirekten
Vergleich gezogen ein indirekten
Vergleich des Bombenkrieges mit dem
Holocaust der so die brennenden
Wohnblöcke verglichen mit den
Krematorien
und das löste Emotionen aus also er hat
dadurch natürlich die Verkaufszahlen
enorm angekurbelt aber die Emotion war
da in der Betrachtung auch dieser
direkte Vergleich wozu das dann führt
zeige ich nachher schon sage ich nachher
gleich
es zeigt aber auch gerade in dieser
Phase dass man dort einen einen
Generationenkonflikt haben in der
Betrachtung des Bombenkrieges die
Forschung darauf sehr scharf reagiert
und was ich in Deutschland merken ab
2002/2003
und das ist vor allem die süß der sich
also hier intensiv befasst hat damit ist
dass die Forschung sich aufgefächert hat
auf einmal war es Gegenstand der
Forschung die erinnerungswelten des
Bombenkrieges zu thematisieren Maßnahmen
des unes zu thematisieren auch zu
schauen wie wirkt dieser Bomben
Gesellschaft das macht er mit einer
Gesellschaft das sind ja Erkenntnisse
die relevant sind die Gegenwart herauf
auch eine gezielte Befragung der
Bildwelten im Sinne einer history fanden
jetzt statt und finden jetzt statt
wir schauen in Österreich aus in
Österreich kann diese Friedrich Debatte
nicht anfällt am deutlichsten sichtbar
2015 anlässlich des Jubiläumsjahres wo
man sich auch das Bombenkrieges annahmen
das da hat man in dem man die
Bombennacht von 12 märz 1945 nachstellte
das ist das sehr gefährliches Datum also
12 März vielleicht um das kurz zu
erklären 12 märz 1945 war ein Angriff
ein Luftangriff auf Wien der die
Innenstadt traf
der also Albertin ein Brandt seitder und
vor allem den Philipp Hof traf der so in
sich einstürzt und über 200 Menschen
lebendig begrub der Trauma sein Trauma
in der gesamtenerzählung es fällt aber
dieser 12 märz 1945 auch mit dem 11.12
märz 1938 zusammen wenn man ihnen das
Gedenktag beginnt und dann haben wir
wieder die doppelte Opfer deswegen ist
es sehr gefährliches Datum das aber in
dem Fall 2015 zusammengelegt wurde das
wurde dann also auch noch
verfremdet indem man ihn als Nacht
Angriff inszeniert hat der Sony
stattgefunden hat und man hat nach dir
nachts die Effekte bringen konnte
sich aber mehrere Dinge mit überlegt hat
ja also die vor allem der Inszenierung
2015 oder mehr als unglücklich hat aber
letztlich gezeigt dass die Bomben die
kriegsdiskussionen in Deutschland dann
zu diesem Zeitpunkt schon längst hatte
in Österreich nicht stattfand und bis
heute das kaum stattfand
wie kann man es allgemein betrachten
Bombenkrieg und das ist tatsächlich die
Conclusio die ich treffen muss ist eine
nach wie vor offene Wunde an der wir
arbeiten
und der Generationen Arbeiten es ist
auch Besonderheit weil das über so viele
Generationen jetzt schon springt es ist
Teil einer populär Kultur wir sehen uns
auf der filmischen Ebene ganz deutlich
es finden aber auch ganz starke
übernahmen im rechtsradikalen Milieu
statt und da ist der stehende Begriff
der Bomben Holocaust ist der stehende
Begriff der verwendet wird
wir merken aber auch dass ich Museen
sehr schwer tun schwer tun den
Bombenkrieg in seiner Tiefe in seiner
Dimensionen in seiner Wirkung zu
erfassen als komplexes und weiß eine
offene Wunde ist
das merken wir auch an der Frage der
fliegerlöhnische Justiz nicht dafür den
Historiker Klaus Michael Mann im Jahr
2015 zitieren die Täter und Opferrollen
scheinen hier also hier ein Bombenkrieg
noch genauso verteilt zu sein wie vor 60
Jahren den terrorfliegern haben die
Bombenopfer bis heute nicht wirklich
verziehen Zitat Ende
sieht man deutlich an den Gedenkstein
hier oben auf der Insel Borkum wo man
gedenken wollte ermordeten
amerikanischen Fliegern es gab breite
Proteste auf der Insel schlussendlich
hat man sich dann dazu durchgerungen
dass das Wort Mord nicht in den Mund zu
nehmen und sie sehen auf der Tafel ist
den Schriftzug amerikanische Flieger die
nach ihrer Gefangennahme auf tragische
Weise erleben verloren haben also das
verdeutlicht des noch einmal diesen
emotionalen
Begriff in diesem Kontext
ich komme jetzt zu einer conclusion
damit auch zum Schluss ich habe kurz
dargestellt der Bombenkrieg in seiner
Wirkung auf die Gesellschaft auch diese
eingeschränkte Wahrnehmung diese
Reduktion aufhören
der Bereich der unter- und Überlegenheit
in den Gefühlswelten das löst das auch
sehr und das ist etwas was uns noch
heute bei Luft kriegt ein sehr großes
Thema aufmacht die Wirkung auf
Herrschaft
ganz zentral auch weil es eine Estrichen
sich danach ausgerichtet hat die
Reaktionsmechanismus und dann klar das
konstrukturgemeinschaft kriegst Deutung
und Feindbild zu stärken und dann
letztlich auch eine Freigabe von Gewalt
als Gedächtnisort ist es eben diese
offene Wunde über Generationen die stark
mit der opferwahrnehmung arbeitet und
genau in dieser Hinsicht haben Museen zu
arbeiten das geschichtliche Museum
thematisiert diesen Bombenkrieg auch
auch in einer Form dass wir uns in
Zukunft überlegen müssen wir müssen
wieder stärker thematisieren und auch
anders thematisieren und ich darf von
dort aus auch einen Schwung und einen
Schritt in die Gegenwart nehmen denn mit
Blick auf die Ukraine in einer anderen
Form des Luftkrieges auch gegen eine
Bevölkerung sind wir gerade wieder dabei
zu erleben wie hier offene Wunden
entstehen die auch hier wieder über
Generationen weiter wirken werden
herzlichen Dank für die Aufmerksamkeit
[Applaus]
dass es jetzt noch die Möglichkeit geben
die eine oder andere Frage
zu beantworten
ihr fliegt der Einkommens kurz zu halten
Direktor würden sie in ihre Systematik
auch kurz darauf eingehen wo die ganze
breit gefächerte Organisation hier zu
verorten wäre danke auch in der
Erinnerungskultur ja
es ist ein weiterer Punkt also vor allem
auch bei den flakhelfen da haben wir
natürlich noch andere Dimensionen weil
da fassen wir danach noch andere
Bereiche einer Gesellschaft immer vorher
aus diesem militärischen Kontext
herausgeklammert haben das heißt
Jugendliche und Frauen also hier damit
integriert sind und in sehr vielerlei
Hinsicht auch im helferbereich letztlich
auch Zwangsarbeiter zum Beispiel das
heißt also wir haben ja noch andere
Auffächerung
in dramatischer Art und Weise und das
ist in der Erinnerungskultur durchaus
weiter getragen weil es meistens jüngere
Personen waren das heißt also hier und
der Erzählungen dann auch länger
angehalten und es weiter dass emotional
besetzt denn die Bilder der Flakhelfer
und nicht nur der Flagge helfen sondern
auch der luftschutzpolizisten Luft
Polizisten sind noch einmal andere also
von meistens junge Personen
luftschutzhilfspolizisten die dann auf
die Straßen gingen um zu schauen ob
Blindgänger liegen und die die
dramatischen Folgen dann erlebt haben
das heißt auch gerade in den
erinnerungswelten haben wir noch einmal
eine ganz besondere Form
Erinnerungen Wahrnehmung
ja danke dir ich hätte eine Frage und
zwar weiß man etwas darüber wie die
Ansichten in der deutschen Luftwaffe
selber waren zu dem Thema ich frage das
deshalb weil ja auch in der Forschung
unbestritten ist dass die deutsche
Luftwaffe selber schon vom ersten Tag
des Krieges an auch ähnliche
Terrorangriffe auf auf Länder geflogen
hat wie Polen und anderen oder eben Teil
auch der der Kriegsstrategie war und
meine Frage ist jetzt mindestens zum
Beispiel in der Luftwaffe diese
gesellschaftliche Diskussion über über
den Bombenkrieg der Alliierten als als
Verbrechen dargestellt wird man aber
selber weiß dass man eigentlich das
selber auch getan hat ob das in
irgendeiner Weise diskutiert wurde
natürlich findet man sowas nicht
unbedingt offiziell Dokumenten aber es
gibt ja zum Beispiel die
abwehrprotokolle von von deutschen
Soldaten wie kritischer oder US
Gefangenschaft waren wo eben über solche
Themen auch geredet wurde
es ist sehr spannende Frage wir erkennen
es ganz deutlich auch hier in einer ganz
spezifischen Schiene die das in es
Regime aufbaut und es ist die Schiene
der Vergeltung das heißt also genau und
in die Logik der Eskalation des
luftkriegers also das heißt mit den
ersten Angriffen der deutschen Luftwaffe
auf Städter wie Rotterdam Warschau
Gegenangriffen dann die Stadt gefunden
haben und in weiterer Folge Luftschlacht
um England also mit den Angriffen auf
Berlin London und dergleichen baut es
sich die Logik einer Vergeltung auf das
heißt man hat es letztlich das
verbrecherische natürlich immer den
Gegner zugeordnet und sich selbst in der
reaktionsrolle gesehen und das wurde
durchaus verinnerlicht an mehreren
Stellen verinnerlicht und je weiter der
Krieg voranschritt wurde das nur umso
deutlicher also wie kennen auch
Protokolle von Nachtjagd Piloten
deutschen die also natürlich auch die
Gefühlswelten beschreiben die Sie haben
wenn Sie über einen brennende Stadt
fliegen also wo die Hitze zu spüren ist
und wie dramatisch das waren und
nichtsdestotrotz ist dort das was man
diesen im Kontext bitterlichen
Kriegsführung nimmt in der deutschen
Luftwaffe schon noch ein Thema bis zu
einem gewissen Grad und wurde auch sehr
lange in der Erinnerung weiter tradiert
auch in der Frage das sauberen Luftwaffe
ja da kommt es auch wieder so eine neben
Diskussion zu Wehrmacht
es gibt aber Beispiele wo zum Beispiel
die lünejustiz an abgeschossenen fliegen
auch Luftwaffe Soldaten integriert sein
also wo dieser Zorn auf die
Terrorflieger ganz ganz deutlich auch
innerhalb der Luftwaffe zu sehen ist und
auch nicht das gleichsetzen das
gleichsetzen mit mit dem Gegner
nichtsdestotrotz was wir aus den
Erfahrungen von abgeschossenen
Flugzeugbesatzungen wissen auch sehr
deutlich gesagt ist genau der Moment wo
abgeschossene Flieger ein
Kriegsgefangenenlager der Luftwaffe
reicht dann haben sie sich selber sicher
gefühlt
also das ist dann der nächste Punkt der
Gefahr eher davor wahrgenommen
eine Herrschaft mein Name ist Hubert
spollek geboren am 24 januar 1933 in
Hamburg
Finkenau ich lebte dort mit meinen
Eltern und meinen Vater der Tod vor 38
eine Anstellung bei der Handelsmarine
hatte und wir lebten in Hamburg Horn auf
der Adresse
hat mich derartig aufgewühlt ich habe
mit dem Gedanken gespielt ist das
überhaupt interessant was sie zu sagen
habe aber ich möchte einen kurzen
Situation in einem
luftschutzkellerschilder
indem wir nachdem der Bombenkrieg
langsam aber sicher fahren immer
regelmäßig
in den Keller muss
außerdem übrigens
als Ausrede vielleicht Geld machen das
ist
in die Schule zu gehen das kam nicht in
Frage am nächsten Morgen wurde wieder in
die Schule gegangen und an diesem
fraglichen Abend als die Sirene
die war für mich erschreckt präzise ja
und so
sind wir wieder in den Keller runter ich
muss vorausschicken 1943 werden
europäischen Corona haben wir dann alles
verloren dürfen und diese Mehrheit
leben wir am Leben es hat uns nicht
also übliche Routine die ganzen
gestiegengemeinschaft in den Keller das
waren vorwiegen Frauen Mütter mit
Kindern und alleinstehende Frau es waren
kein einziger Mann in diesem Keller und
man richtete sich auf eine lange Nacht
ein auf einmal gab es einen
unglaublichen Knall
die Reaktion war dass das Licht ausgeht
das elektrische Licht die Frauen allen
die auf ein Kommando am momentan
geschrieben dann war es ruhig und zwar
gespenstigen ruhig das Licht wieder an
und wir haben alle ausgeschaut wie die
wie die Bäcker junge die machen schnell
eingetaucht hat es ist diese Wende sind
mit einem billigen kalkstoff bemalt
worden
es hat uns nichts getroffen aber ich
vergleiche das Ganze immer mit einer
schuhschacht und die ich an die Hand
nehme in der Schuh schade es ist unser
Bunker sitzen wir und warten was da
kommt und auf einmal
auch schon am nächsten Morgen auf dem
Weg in die Schule habe ich dann als
Schüler feststellen können das Haus
neben uns auch durch Handvoll Treffer
Weg rasieren so viel zu meiner werte ich
danke dir
[Applaus]
herzlichen Dank
danke
mein Name ist Franz Jahrgang 41
[Musik]
in der Luftschutzkeller erlebt wo die
nächsten Einschläge 15 Meter entfernt
waren ich möchte die Details
eine ich komme aus diesem Grund für
dieses Thema immer wieder interessiert
als Jugendlicher bis jetzt höhere Alter
und
habe mir Literatur sozusagen zugelegt
die beste das beste Buch über den
luftkriegen hat ein gewisser crailing
aus England geschrieben unbedingt
Deutsch Feindlichkeit zugestehen muss
und der kommt auch zu dem Schluss das
Vorteils und Churchill
[Musik]
das negativen Figur der Geschichte
erzählen ich habe nur wie bringt man die
Systeme dass sie da sehr gut behandelt
haben danke dafür wie bringt man das an
die Bevölkerung heran
könnte was Zeitzeuge noch in Schulen
gehen zu machen wir stehen und gehen
kann und den Kindern das erklären man
könnte die bezirksmuseen dazu anregen
diese Zeit in Ihren Räumen darzustellen
das passiert nämlich auch nicht in
Hietzing zum Beispiel mit dem Vorgänger
von dem jetzigen Königstein
Doktor ist so weit gebracht dass es so
Tafeln also blättertafel ist aufgestellt
hat die
bezirksdirektorin von Penzing habe mich
gefragt ich hatte Benzin überhaupt
Schäden gegeben
wie Haus das ist kaputt gewesen und
gutes Haus von meinen Großvater das
nochmal
ebenfalls kaputt und sofort und so
weiter also man müsste das unter die
Leute bringen das ist das Wesentliche
wenn wir dort sitzen die älteren Herren
die wissen sowieso sehr viel darüber
aber die Jugend hat keine Ahnung der
dieses tägliche Gedenken an den
Holocaust wo sie in Ordnung ist ja
absolut
verstellt die die Breite Sicht auch die
auf das Gesamtbild eines Krieges und da
unten kriegt ist eine Besonderheit und
auch das sollte man eingehen danke
[Applaus]
ich glaube es ist ganz ganz wichtig auch
die Dimensionen des Kriegers
darzustellen aber wenn alle in der
gesamten Breite also das heißt auch das
was in dem Fall Bomben kriegen mit
auslöst das was ich geschildert habe das
heißt es ist nicht zu entkoppeln es ist
auch nicht so ein koppeln vom Holocaust
das Spiel zusammen das ist ein ein Teil
ein sherrschaft auch ohne die
Thematisierung des Bombenkrieges wäre
auch kaum möglich und umgekehrt und
dieses Zusammenspiel das ist letztlich
ist auch die große Kunst das in
Gesamtheit zu erklären also das heißt du
auch wohin führt ein totalitäres Regime
wohin führen Feindbilder letztlich und
dann in weiterer Folge was lösen Kriege
aus und deswegen ist auch dieser nicht
danke durchaus auch für die Wortmeldung
jetzt und ich habe es nicht ganz ohne
Grund dass die Ukraine immer wieder
erwähnte das müssen wir uns natürlich
bewusst machen was kriege in einer in
dieser Form wie sie geführt verlässlich
auslösen können
Kerstin von Linken Universität Wien
vielen Dank Herr Kollege Hoffmann wir
haben jetzt so viel gehört über das
leichtes Bombenkriegs dass sie auch die
Opfer unter den Zwangsarbeitern ganz
deutlich erwähnt haben denn wir müssen
uns auch klar machen diese Angriffe
haben die Städte getroffen und
Kriegsgefangene oder jüdische
Zwangsarbeiter waren ohne Schutz quasi
auf der Straße in so einem notdürftigen
holzunterstellen und als der andere
vorbei warten die ersten die dann
angefangen haben aufzuräumen die Leichen
aus dem drum und zu holen und das war
eine unglaubliche unmenschliche Art und
Weise und ich bin wirklich dankbar dass
sie darauf hingewiesen haben vielen Dank
[Musik]
herzlichen Dank für die Fragen dann darf
ich jetzt noch bevor ich zu meinen
Abschluss warten kaum noch den
Vizepräsidenten unseres Fördervereins
kurz um seine Worte bitten
Zufälle sind die Würze des Lebens
und einen kleinen Zufall habe ich gerade
vorhin erlebt als ich gehört habe dass
die informationsoffiziere unter uns sind
vor 50 Jahren habe ich meinen
erstinformationsoffiziers Einsatz gehabt
ich freue mich dass ich daher in einem
Kreis diese 50 Jahre feiern darf ihr
seid als Liebe Kameradinnen und
Kameraden die diese Gedanken die heute
gebracht worden sind und irgendwie
fordert worden sind auch weitergeben
aber das war gar nicht der Zufall von
dem ich reden wollte der Zufall vor dem
ich reden wollte war der dass ich vor
ungefähr einem Monat an einem Artikel
über die Flieger Abwehr am Bisamberg
geschrieben habe und über die
Luftangriffe auf diesem Bisamberg
am selben Tag habe ich die
Einladungskarte von dir bekommen mit dem
Flugzeug das sozusagen typisch war für
die Luftangriffe auf Wien oder auf dem
Bisamberg das ist auch noch kein
besonderer Zufall aber das amselben
Abend mein Computer mir ein Zeichen
gegeben hat das ein E-Mail eingelangt
ist das ist jetzt der wahre Zufall denn
auf diesem E-Mail ist gestanden dass ein
Mitglied unserer Gesellschaft und dem
Verein der Freunde des
heeresgeschichtlichen Museums einen
Bodenfund von Bisamberg übergeben möchte
das war natürlich für mich am
präsensationell wenn ich gerade arbeite
am Bisamberg und ich erfahre dass wir
uns wie ein Geschenk bekommen ein
Bodenfund aus 1945 aus dem Bisamberg das
war nur immer nicht die wahre Zufall der
wahre Zufall war was gefunden worden ist
und was uns überreicht hat und da haben
wir gedacht es gibt keinen besseren
Augenblick aus den jetzigen um es dir
halt Direktor im Namen der Gesellschaft
der Feinde des heeresgeschichtlichen
Museums es dauerlike zu überreichen
und den ganzen Vortrag hat mich das
verfolgt dass ich das heute dir
übergeben soll wenn du so viele
Stichworte dafür gegeben hast
es ist ein kleines unscheinbare Plakette
es ist das Typenschild eines
amerikanischen Bombers der am Bisamberg
abgeschlossen wurde
also für mich wiederum eine Geschichte
zu meinem Buch die man nicht erfinden
kann die immer auch nicht finden kann
die muss einem zufallen und das tolle es
ist ein Mitglied dass uns das geschenkt
hat er ist unter uns möchte aber anonym
bleiben aber das zum Anlass genommen um
eine Arbeit für sein Studium zu
erstellen
und da muss ich euch sagen liebe
Freundinnen und Freunde
da reden wir schon ein bisschen den
Rücken herunter er hat nämlich alle
Besatzungsmitglieder von diesem
amerikanischen Bomber der auf dem
Bisamberg abgeschossen wurden ist
rekapitulieren können und damit ist
eines passiert aus den terrorfliegern
hat er hier eine Lebensgeschichte
gemacht und die darf ich dir überreichen
vielleicht ist sie der Startschuss für
das was du vorhast ein Kunst wie hast du
so schön nicht schön
kontextualisieren dieses Themas eine
kleine wissenschaftliche Arbeit die
Lebensgeschichte von sechs
amerikanischen so egal von 6 Soldaten
erschüttern dabei ist dass von diesen
sechs Soldaten ein einziger nämlich der
Kommandant des Flugzeugs an als Adresse
der nächsten Angehörigen seine Frau
angegeben hat und alle anderen fünf ihre
Mutter
das waren alles junge Bumm und das zum
Beispiel der Bogen vom Terrorpiloten zu
dem gefallenen Kameraden
[Applaus]
vielleicht noch ganz kurz
auch jetzt an den anonymen Spender
gewissermaßen herzlichen Dank das ist
eine sehr große Freude und immer wenn
ich wenn ich derartige Dinge auch sehe
und wo wo letztlich das Schicksal von
Menschen aus dem dunklen irgendwo ins
Licht geholt wird das ist ja bewegende
Sache und das ist auch etwas das nehme
ich mit das nehme ich jetzt auch aus
Auftrag mit für die Weiterentwicklung
des jahresgeschichtlichen Museums die
Geschichte der Menschen hervorzukehren
zu zeigen und letztlich auch zu
thematisieren und zu diskutieren und
sichtbar zu machen herzlichen Dank dafür
[Applaus]
meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren in
altbewährter Tradition darf ich sie
jetzt erstens einmal Danke dass sie bis
jetzt geblieben sind aber der Vortrag
hat es glaube ich geschuldet und sie
sehen und sie haben vielleicht auch
schon bemerkt dass ich jetzt sie können
positiv in die Zukunft sehen dass ich
die Vorträge jetzt vielleicht in eine
andere Art und Dimension begeben werden
und wir haben das feste Ziel das so
weiter zu verfolgen die nächsten
Veranstaltungen darf ich an dieser
Stelle auch gleich ankündigen und
passend zum tatsächlichen passend zum
Thema
25.4 nächsten Dienstag eröffnet unsere
Zweigstelle das Militär Luftfahrtmuseum
in Zeltweg wieder seine Tore es ist ein
herzlich eingeladen das zu besuchen eine
einzigartige Ausstellung zur Geschichte
der Österreichischen
Luftstreitkräfte die dort zu sehen ist
vor allem auch wirklich in einem
historischen
fliegerobjekt dazu darf ich Sie recht
herzlich einladen am 7 mai gibt es zwei
Veranstaltungen das Museums das eine ist
hier bei uns im Museum da haben wir
unser großes Kinder Prozess also bitte
kommen Sie mit Ihren Kindern
Enkelkindern Kindern die sie finden hier
ins Museum es wird sicher eine schöne
spannende und vor allem sehr
actionreiche Veranstaltungen für unsere
jüngsten Besucher werden gleichzeitig
gibt es für die Marine Interessierten
zum ersten Mal im heurigen Jahr die
Möglichkeit unsere
patrouillenbotsstaffel in Korneuburg in
der alten Werft zu besichtigen das wird
nur immer aus organisatorischen Gründen
jeden ersten Sonntag im Monat von Mai
bis September möglich sein und last but
not least sie werden es wahrscheinlich
schon gesehen haben als versucht haben
sich hinzusetzen dass dort schon die
nächste Informationskarte liegt und zwar
vom nächsten Vortrag diesmal kein
lufthema der vortragen ist dasselbe
nämlich unser neuer Direktor der zur
Thematik im Westen nichts Neues sprechen
wird sie wissen ja vielleicht dass der
Roman der 1928 verfasst worden ist
gleich zwei Jahre später zum ersten Mal
verfilmt worden ist in verschiedenen
Varianten und vor zwei Jahren gab es
eine Neuverfilmung und über die
Unterschiede in dieser Darstellung wird
daher Direktor sprechen zu guter Letzt
möchte ich mich bedanken dass sie heute
da waren ich wünsche Ihnen einen guten
Nachhauseweg und ich möchte Ihnen
vielleicht mitgeben dass die und
vielleicht haben Sie es schon
mitbekommen und auch wenn Sie sich mit
dem Museumsmitarbeitern unterhalten es
herrscht gerade wirklich in jedem Winkel
und in jeder Büroecke eine ganz ganz
besondere Aufbruchstimmung und wir
würden uns sehr sehr freuen wenn Sie an
dieser Aufbruchstimmung teilhaben uns
die treu erhaltener regelmäßig und oft
wie heute zu uns ins Museum kommen damit
wir gemeinsam da direkt und das Team das
Museums diesen Weg in die Zukunft gehen
können danke schön schönen Abend
[Applaus]